this cotton yarn is used to make
shoelaces Worzel Okocha chef ski is
preparing it for processing she's worked
here at cks shoelaces in Wuppertal
for most of her life I did my training
and then I got a job here and I simply
stuck around over all those years she's
experienced highs and lows with a small
family-owned business yota plots is the
owner of the company which has been in
her family for five generations now so
keeping up that tradition is a priority
no our goal is not to be as profitable
as possible we're more interested in a
quality product happy employees and of
course satisfied customers these are the
colors for next year's collection the
company does its own marketing and sales
they gave up trying to compete with
discount manufacturers in Asia after one
bad experience all stuck even divided in
2002 we had this incident where we
purchased cheap yarn that turned out to
contain toxins and then we continue to
look for cheaper suppliers at the
request of our customers but we
eventually have to realize that this
really wasn't working out and that this
was simply not for us Tomica Zardoz is
nice knit ones I read quite a few other
companies in Germany have come to a
similar realization according to
researchers in Berlin and many of them
are small family-run businesses the
researchers surveyed hundreds of small
and medium sized enterprises in Germany
a third of the 700 companies we talked
to said they're perfectly happy with
their current size and that essentially
they don't want to get bigger
back at the shoelace company in will
part of the 33 employees are working on
their next order
once the laces are woven they're trimmed
into various sizes the company has sales
of two and a half million euros a year
most of the customers are shoe companies
in Europe but some clients are in China
and India
- the firm has lost some business
because of its focus on quality that
costs of course we had this one customer
and there was simply not willing to pay
for quality it was their procurement
manager and there are other customers
that we lost but we've replaced them one
of the product lines is made out of a
man-made cellulose based fiber called
tinsel it's a sustainable product just
right for a company whose top priority
is not growth but sustaining tradition